no
[Música]
hola soy anna vaccarella periodista
aunque prefiero que me conozcan como una
contadora de historias y hoy voy a
compartir con ustedes una historia
personal
pídele a dios que sea un cáncer en la
sangre y no en los ovarios
con semejante mensaje
desperté después de una operación de 9
horas
que le pida que que le pida qué cosa que
hago aquí qué pasó
mis hijas apenas tienen cuatro años que
va a ser de ella sin mí
mi trabajo debo ir al canal a leer
noticias mi programa de radio son
diarios nunca faltó
así cambio el juego en mi vida el 21 de
julio de 2015
quiero pedirles que hagamos un ejercicio
mental
te has preparado para ser un gran
lanzador de flechas llegó el día toma el
arco y toma la flecha has entrenado los
brazos
has entrenado la puntería el equilibrio
el balance y llegó el momento
todo más el arco pones la flecha estirar
la cuerda
igualdad
la flecha va volando
a partir de ese momento no tienes
control
ella está
desplazándose hacia lo que tú esperas
sea tu diana esa diana puede llamarse
dinero o fortuna suerte amor salud esa
diana puede tener cualquier nombre un
sueño algo por lo que has trabajado
intensamente
pero te tengo una mala noticia en la
mayoría de las oportunidades
esa flecha no hace diana
cae en cualquier otro sitio
en el pantano es un río en la tierra en
un árbol
entonces tienes dos caminos es de
resistir
o el de ceder
el primero
el más usado por la mayoría de las
personas ese fue mi camino durante gran
parte de mi vida
resistir
implica negarse
el que resiste saca entonces la cinta
métrica y mide la distancia que le faltó
para que la flecha hiciera diana el que
resiste comienza a llenarse de culpa a
mirar atrás que falle que pasó que hice
mal quien tuvo la culpa a estar
conectado con el pasado y a negarse a
ver su presente
resistir se genera una contracción
interna es negatividad nada que parta de
una resistencia interna logra algo
distinto que una resistencia externa el
universo no ayuda la vida no colaborará
es imposible que el sol entre cuando las
ventanas están cerradas
la otra opción
exceder
cuando se des te abres a la vida
independientemente de que esté cediendo
ante una enfermedad mortal que esté
cediendo ante el peor de tus problemas
ahí está la flecha cayó ahí la recoges
sueltas tu plan está ya en el pasado y
diseñas un nuevo plan
mi flecha cayó en la habitación 318 del
urológico san román un centro clínico
aquí en caracas
en ese momento
comenzó un proceso
duro difícil que voy a compartir con
ustedes
porque allí tuve que volver a lanzar la
flecha
con menos fuerza sí pero tal vez con un
poco más de sabiduría porque queridos
amigos en la vida
todo es un intento
cuenta una historia que walt disney
cuando era niño tenía una maestra que lo
invitó a dibujar unas flores este niño
dibuja a dos flores hablando entonces la
maestra cuando ve el dibujo lo increpa y
le dice que para las flores no hablan
y este niño haciendo gala ya de su
inteligencia y habilidades cuenta la
historia le respondió maestra serán sus
flores las que no hablen
hablan tus flores
escuchas a tus flores sus flores son
esta capacidad que tenemos todos de
conectarnos con lo esencial de
conectarnos con la magia de conectarnos
con todo ese potencial
creador que tenemos dentro de nosotros
sus flores son esa posibilidad de lograr
tus sueños son esa posibilidad de entrar
directamente en sintonía con las cosas
esenciales en la vida
lamentablemente el día a día no hay
tiempo lo vertiginosa en que se ha
transformado nuestra vida
el levantate trabaja trata de subsistir
trata de mantenerte para volverte a
acostar a dormir pocas horas eso sí
porque tienes que volver a levantarte
volver a trabajar es un torbellino
y en la medida que esa vida es la que
llevamos nuestras flores van perdiendo
pétalos
hasta llega un momento que no las
escuchamos más
y entonces como nos estamos perdiendo la
mitad de la historia la mitad del
panorama nos concentramos y nos
convencemos de que la felicidad sólo la
podemos lograr cuando compre cuando
tenga cuando gane
cuando conquisté y por consecuencia la
infelicidad llega cuando no compro
cuando no tengo cuando él no gano cuando
no cumpliste
resulta que así como de cierta esa vida
vertiginosa y son ciertos los problemas
que te agobian y te quitan la paz
también son igual de ciertos los
milagros que te rodean esos milagros que
dejaste de ver por la rutina por el
hartazgo por la falta de tiempo y por la
falta de conexión
hoy estoy aquí para demostrarte que esos
milagros son incluso más importantes y
más valiosos que tus problemas porque
son la verdadera fuente de la felicidad
memorial sloan kettering cancer center
nueva york-
primera venida / primera venida y la
york
las calles
68-67 allí fui trasladada para hacerme
un trasplante de médula
si le pedí a dios por un linfoma y si
efectivamente ese fue el diagnóstico
lamentablemente era muy agresivo sólo el
6 por ciento
son tan letales y ese me había tocado a
mí
caía el peor invierno en años en la
ciudad de novio
hacía mucho frío
mis días los pasaba sentada en una silla
y ese era mi gran reto el médico me dijo
'han a tu peor enemigo es la cama
procura estar el menor tiempo posible
pasaba el día asomado a una ventana
porque la primera habitación tenía
ventanas las otras no viendo la vida
afuera
mucho frío estaba en mi corazón en mi
alma yo no comía alimentos
nutrían por la vía y sin embargo mi
cuerpo
vomitaba 7 y 8 veces porque se sentía
envenenado los químicos la terapia
química las quimioterapias para barrer
mi sistema inmunológico eran casi
letales era ir muriendo poco a poco para
luego renacer
y en ese panorama
todos los días llegaba una señora a
esterilizar aquella burbuja
y para que vean
hasta donde la vida quiso enseñarme mi
alma se conectaba todos los días con ese
ser que era el ser más humilde de todos
los que entraban en esa habitación mi
habitación estaba siempre con médicos
con eminencias con estudiantes
universitarios de medicina con
enfermeras y sin embargo yo me conecté
fue con la señora que limpiaba la
habitación
la que de seguro no tenía algún diploma
superé
así la vida me enseñó que todo lo del
trabajo el esfuerzo ganar la fama la
popularidad no importaba yo quería hacer
ella la más humilde de todas porque ella
tenía lo que yo también tuve que nunca
me hizo feliz
y que ahora luchaba
hasta la muerte para recuperarlo
ella tenía salud
hoy quiero contarles cómo volví a la
vida
me abracé
abracé mi dolor
me di permiso para llorar llorar
sentirme la más grande de las víctimas
llenarme de rabia porque a mí mis hijas
tienen 4 años porque me pasa esto a mí
no me lo merezco
me sentí
terrible mente desvalida abandonada
maltratada lanzada violentamente al
hombrillo de la vida
abracé a mi víctima
cree y para mí la fe siempre ha sido un
apoyo los momentos
que me llenaban de paz
era cuando oraba
acepte
y allí comenzó el proceso
al llenarse de luz
gracias a una enfermera que estaba
todavía en caracas en el primer tramo
del proceso no se sabía el nivel de
gravedad que yo tenía
y bueno en esas primeras quimioterapias
eran por la vía y entonces llegaba la
enfermera y cada vez para tomarme la vía
yo lloraba me dolía y entonces él
intentaba me pillaba no podía hasta que
esta mujer sin ningún tipo de compasión
me dijo anna o tú pones de tu parte o no
avanzamos así llores así te quejes así
este es como estés yo te tengo que poner
la vida y te tengo que poner el
tratamiento colaborar
cada palabra llegó a donde tenía que
llegar
y comencé yo a entender que debía ceder
que debía aceptar mi presente que debía
tomar esa flecha que estaba en esa sala
de quimioterapia
y debía
volverla
el dolor siempre igual pero les confieso
que no había tanto sufrimiento
que todo era más expedito y que sabía la
tomaba de una manera más rápida
como les digo allí comenzó el proceso a
llenarse de luz
me entregué
no desde el concepto en castellano que
podemos entender me entregué me rendí no
me entregué
a mi presente a lo que me ocurría
y paradójicamente fui feliz
muy feliz
con poco muy poco
porque si esos eran los últimos meses
cuando todavía estaba en venezuela antes
de irme a nueva york y pasar casi cinco
meses sin mis hijas y luego el regreso
si esos eran los últimos meses serían
vividos intensamente
y era profundamente feliz disfrutando un
amanecer
por cierto
cuántos atardeceres has presenciado
era profundamente feliz abrazando a mi
hija en ese momento en ese minuto en ese
instante
tenía la felicidad que nunca había
experimentado con la fama los premios
los reconocimientos
el carro nuevo
también en ese proceso
de ir avanzando poco a poco viví un día
a la vez
vivo un día a 9
a ratos vivía una hora a la vez media
hora a la vez tres horas a la vez
no quería saber qué iba a pasar después
viví aferrada a mi presente
y agradecí
agradezco cada vivir
agradecer
respirar
agradecer dar un paso
he ido a nueva york muchas veces en mi
vida y producto de todo este tratamiento
han sido más de las que podría haber y
les confieso que los minutos más felices
que he vivido en nueva york fue cuando
después de cuatro meses
pude salir de la burbuja
bajar a la calle
sí
estaba en pijama
con guantes de látex azul con tapabocas
y créanme que en el 2016 el tapabocas no
era lo que representa hoy en día que es
casi una prenda de vestir para nosotros
no tenía nada
pero pude dar los pasos pude respirar
ese aire pude ver los taxis los carros
la gente
no sé si se veían
y ese agradecimiento me hizo tan feliz
ya para finalizar
quiero compartir con ustedes un último
cuento una última historia
para ingresar en el memorial sloan
kettering cancer center el 26 de enero
de 2016 para el trasplante de médula
y vamos a pie mi mamá y yo mi mamá fue
la única que me acompañó en todo el
proceso y vamos a pie desde el lugar
donde nos quedábamos hasta el hospital a
mitad de camino había una tienda
y allí estaban unos zapatos que desde el
primer día me encantaron
y yo íbamos a tiempo con mi mamá uno
siempre va a tiempo
le pedí a mi mamá que entráramos en la
tienda
ella se desconcertó hija tenemos que ir
al hospital
vamos a encarar mamá
que no hace una madre al ver a su hija
atravesando momentos tan difíciles
y en esa tienda decidí comprarme los
zapatos
de esa manera mi alma
desafió a todos los diagnósticos médicos
que eran tan difusos como que
hazte el trasplante de médula y vamos a
ver qué pasa en apenas una hora estaba
yo en un quirófano para que me colocara
un puerto para que por allí entrara el
tratamiento yo estaba comprando unos
zapatos
esos zapatos son estas botas
que hoy he decidido ponerme
porque hoy quiero honrar
a esta valiente mujer
que abrazos o adversidad que abrazo su
más profundo everest
que abrazó sus miedos
y que un día a la vez fue capaz de
aceptar lo que le ocurría de recoger su
flecha de abandonar sus planes de
diseñar otros de volver a lanzar y
seguir fallando la diana pero seguir
intentándolo
fue capaz de conectarse con lo esencial
con lo que verdaderamente
nos proporciona la felicidad y también
tengo estas gotas para honrarte a ti
amiga amigo que en este momento estás
atravesando toda adversidad
a partir de mi regreso a la vida
a partir de mi regreso a caminar a
respirar a salir
mi única misión además de acompañar a
mis bellas hijas que dios me los bendiga
siempre
y contar mi historia
es inspirarte es motivarte para que
descubras tus milagros para que veas tus
milagros para que encuentres la
felicidad porque existe una gran
diferencia
/ estar vivo
y saber vivir
muchas gracias